welcome Pintus video plane Veeru Tom
reroute on from Spain okay let's see if
I can't get above 2200 oh man that's not
a good time let's see okay a scotch game
check okay I won't get over 2200 with
this game but maybe within the next
couple of games yeah the scotch with
Bishop b4 check the line I'm really like
to play again this this variation and
maybe I really should look at night f6 I
had this in a 15-minute game recently
and 90 f6 is really a good move i mean
but i have simply have not yet studied
it hmm gathered re strange move here
because i have g54 for example our queen
g3 problem there's also just the the
bishop capture that's not too bad and
also and when you need to take and now
how to cover c7 yeah i thought this
actually just the Queen
can try night a three to see for this
idea me i would i have d 5 this is what
i was thinking but maybe then queen d3s
is playable as ugly as it looks Carly d6
eid 6 neglects neglect c7 if he goes in
ilc for there's also be five hanging but
this 96 check of course that's not great
hmm
you know what some attack the queen with
h5 yeah maybe this one getting it off
this a g7 Conrad always is somewhat
annoying not sure where you will go to
page four yeah there's still this and
the check on d6 hmm
yeah I can induce king of eight this
looks yeah maybe one night c4 I can then
simply take Knight f3 this Quincy five
no that's not really convincing what I
played here check white salts that I
really should be totally refuted but i
didn't manage okay is there some way to
get in some attack myself like Knight f6
three four heads not so threatening
anything I probably messin with the rook
well that's amazingly terrible yeah
before before I serve a queen track
I can take you five pitches wow I really
a child position my GF 6 is still
playable but that's that's really am
also very dangerous
yeah my tix there is there a double
checks tons of double checks with 97 99
h7 double check Wow poo I really don't
know what to do a play about games and
apply total nonsense in them and I play
total nonsense in my regular game scene
it's really weird when this this is a 9
p-5 is just just not good but I didn't
refute it I simply didn't refute it
yeah what's the most precise way to do
it yeah well it is this this kind of
move 95 is really telling like okay I'm
going to make you I'm going to deuce
yeah and I don't really think I can be
mated he quickly I mean wide structures
totally wrecked yeah the computer gives
d6 with a big advantage and then and
after Queen waters King the aid yeah
maybe maybe this is the the recipe
Queenie 59 f 6 coming there is no attack
here now that's probably the best way to
do it and hear ya night c4 so it's just
a strong threat here T and this is fraud
this is already beyond saving up yeah
I'm night c4 is too strong right here
there is no way to save it now that's
some simple and totally is sufficient
yeah I must play d 6 195 is just better
really Queen g3 is the writings and down
and leads to interesting play yeah our
next time I should probably play Knight
f6 and just be but just be totally fine
the I know that it is something like
this and d5 but I really don't know the
exact line like has excellent
development obviously under yeah maybe I
should just play it next time even if I
haven't managed to look it up because of
this kind of game is really frustrating
okay thanks for watching